this is Greta thundberg and this is the
Swedish Parliament thundberg is 15 years
old and she is doing a school strike for
climate
[Music]
sitting there alone she is smiled at and
even insulted some say go back to school
others tell her to give up
but she doesn't want to listen and
continues and soon there are a few
others who like her ideas and admire her
commitment
and then one day the local press comes
does an interview and Greta's photo goes
around the world
joined Greta soon became many and many
became millions and in countries all
around the world young people began
expressing their opinions about climate
change because they want to build a
better future
used brights that are laid down in the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
accordingly everyone has the right to
express their opinion freely and to meet
freely and peacefully with others so
what exactly is freedom of speech and
where does it end
[Music]
foreign
of speech is a principle that supports
our freedom to articulate opinions and
ideas without the fear of retaliation
censorship or legal sanction
it protects all forms of communication
from speech to text to Art and is a
constitutional law of liberal societies
freedom of speech includes having access
to information to prevent censorship and
limits State control over what we should
and what we shouldn't know and say
it means freedom to express an opinion
regardless of whether the opinion is
Justified or unfounded emotional or
rational valuable or not
and it means you are also allowed to
remain silent and say nothing at all
one form of expressing your opinion is
forming an assembly which usually begins
with two people who come together with a
common purpose but freedom of speech has
its limitations
for example it doesn't mean we can State
something as a fact if it can be proven
Wrong by objective standards
so when Greta says the global biosphere
is being sacrificed so that rich people
can live in luxury she expresses an
opinion because her claim cannot be
objectively verified
but when she begins a speech with my
name is Greta thundberg I am 15 years
old I am from Sweden then that's a
factual assertation because you can
check if all that's correct
in other words the first statement is
protected by the freedom of speech
because it forms an opinion Greta
introducing herself is nice but it's not
protected because it is just a factual
statement which can be verified also not
protected is insulting others or the
assertation of untrue facts
freedom of assembly also has its limits
Gatherings must take place peacefully
and must not jeopardize Public Safety
which can happen if people bring arms or
Riot and become violent so Greta is
allowed to sit in front of the
parliament with posters but she is not
allowed to smear the building with
slogans
Greta used her freedom of speech to
inspire Millions to help put climate
change on top of the political agenda
and while we certainly want more people
to stand up for what they believe in
many of us live in Societies in which
expressing one's opinions isn't possible
so what do you think about freedom of
expression do we need more do we need
less where does it start and where does
it end share your thoughts in the
comments below
foreign
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com